hey leute und willkommen endlich mal
wieder zu einem neuen spotlight dieser
sieht wurde mir zugesendet von dem
youtube user misste feed lp den
kommentar sind wir gerade auf unten
links eingeblendet und zwar lautet der
swiss sieht sachs und angeblich laut ihm
befindet sich auf diesem weg
beziehungsweise in der welt dieser sieht
mit sich ruft eine pyramide mit ganzen
fünf diamanten 27 goldbarren und fünf
eisenbahnen und ich würde sagen wir
schauen uns das dann gleich direkt mal
an ob das auch wirklich so stimmt so
meine lieben freunde den zieht hier habe
ich schon eingegeben der ja wird
zugeschrieben dass theo dass es groß und
hier das ess- oder sonst allgemein alles
klein hier einfach alles so lassen also
wohl typ auf default keine bonus ist
kein kiez an oder könnt ihr ausmachen
das verändert und dem sex und generell
structures auf und klickt man einfach
mal auf create new world also der typ
meinte halt dass dort echt nix
interessante sachen in der kabine sind
und wir spawnen wir schon sehen in einem
flachland hier haben wir ein paar schafe
mit ihr euch ein paar sachen keine
ahnung in denen könnt ihr euch auf jeden
fall eine farm aufbau allgemein immer
leichter sich eine farm im flachland
aufzubauen da was das abgeschnitten als
im dschungel ist immer leichter sich
eine farm im flachland ab aufzubauen
weil hier deutlich mehr tiere spawn
haben wir eine kleine lagune 40 grad
noch alles auf also einen kleinen
kleinen schnuckeligen see mit einer
kleinen höhle die darin mündet
oder ist das natürlich hatte ich richtig
nachgesehen jedenfalls kann man sich
hier ein schönes kleines eine kleine
sommerresidenz einbauen
ja ich glaube das ist ob es ist eine
würde also ganz interessant zu erkunden
lasst mich aus da hat man einen
interessanten lover sehen warum der da
ist weiß ich nicht
das hier wollte ich euch noch zeigen uns
was ihr eine schlucht mit unter anderem
kohle eisen gold habe ich auch irgendwo
gesehen das eisen das kohle gold finde
ich hier gerade nicht naja hier ist auf
jeden fall eine schlucht und hier kommen
wir auch schon zur pyramide direkt neben
dem dschungel bio
er ist die wunderschöne sonne dies auch
ganz speziell nur bei diesem 17
besondere noch dabei das ist unglaublich
ihr habt der allgemeinen dschungel
richtig viele höhlen da sieht man welche
da hinten hat man gerade struktur
gesehen also da geht es überall in den
weg legen welche höhenrain aber aber
aber aber wir schauen uns erst mal die
pyramide an so schöne sternchen so ab
denn da machen wir mal einfach alles
offen
so jetzt achtung dass wir nicht auf die
platte verhalten hier haben wir zwei
diamanten sechs knochen
dort haben wir noch mal neun knochen
also haben wir schon 15 fleisch alten
button und so weiter
ich nehme es mir einfach alles raus hier
sind wieder drei diamanten drin und hier
sind noch alles drin und noch ein paar
sachen also der typ meinte fünf
diamanten das ist doch richtig da meinte
er zwei emery als auch richtig sieben
gold machen ist richtig und 5000 waren
es auch richtig also muss ich sagen muss
dass es mehr inserate spiels die hitler
ich muss sagen mit rapid dank oder
mister feed lp danke an dienst ead was
hier in sondern auch noch erwähnen
könntest das ist echt cooles dass hier
im flachland ist bis in wüste dschungel
fliegen also alles aneinander dass die
hauptsachen in diesem sieg sind echt
alle beim namen nahe beieinander und das
war's dann auch schon wieder von diesem
sieg showcase ich werde hier noch ein
bisschen rum fliegen wird gucken ob ich
ihn sonst noch irgendwas finde ich würde
mich freuen wenn ihr das video in
irgendeiner form bewertet das heißt in
form von daumen hoch wenn es euch
gefallen hat oder daumen runter wenn
jetzt nicht so gut findet und was ich
sagen wollte ihr könnt mir sieht in die
kommentare schreiben und sich das
nächste mal euren skin an da das jetzt
die erste preview nach konz 2.0 das habe
ich mir erst mal gedacht okay kommt
spielt noch mit einem scan aber jetzt
könnt ihr das kind in die kommentare
schreiben die ich dann einfach anziehe
und dann seid ihr vielleicht
beziehungsweise seht ihr euren skin beim
nächsten mal im video
und dann wird auch schon sagen tschüss
und bis zum nächsten mal